will are you there
hey can you hear me oh my god
oh my god
are we going to the movies what are we
doing
god damn i better go to lunch after this
i didn't know we were talking to danny
devito today
all right we got a whole bunch of stuff
we're gonna rip through these charts and
then we'll talk to you about some
sentiment stuff uh afterwards but let's
just start with uh
the on-chain uh data which really the
first on change will actually exchange
uh data which is the price
so obviously bitcoin's fallen in uh in
recent weeks uh what are you thinking
about price what are you seeing in terms
of resistance support etc
sure so we can first just start with a
couple price levels i drew out so i
think um you know the level we were
previously talking about was 40k
um and now that we flip that previous
you know strong support level as
resistance and that's now gonna you know
serve as the most important resistance
for us to you know flip in the in the
local intermediate term
uh and then as well the most you know
the strongest support we have below is
30k
uh that's kind of confluence across
several different time frames so it's
just basic little price levels that uh i
think are important to be watching
and when you look at uh this other chart
you have around coinbase and this idea
of uh front running explain exactly what
happened i saw you tweeting about this
this week and i was fascinated uh that
you were able to find this um what was
happening on coinbase when we kind of
reached that uh that low or that bottom
sure so i think um you know if we really
zoom out we're kind of just in this
range between 30 and 60 call it and so
you know you can look in the order books
and see there's a lot of
uh bids that are stacked around 28 to
30k which were those prior lows from the
summer so i think there's there's a fair
amount of demand down at that support
level but whenever there's you know
whenever there's transparently a lot of
demand in a certain area that'll get
front rank right so someone can say
okay well everyone wants to buy at 30k
i'll just step in and buy it thirty
thousand one dollar right and so in this
case uh you did have an entity that
started to kind of front run some of
those bids that were stacked as we broke
below 33k
and in particular uh the entity or group
of entities seem to be coming from
coinbase so we can see that in several
different ways so first of all just
through looking at volume uh we saw a
large spike in volume coming from
coinbase
we can also see that in the heat map
when we're looking at all the bids and
asks on the heat map and then the third
thing is we can look at something called
cumulative volume delta and so this just
is telling you is price moving to the
bid or the ask
so as you can see this this spike up in
cvd around where we bottomed out right
below uh 30k we saw that large uptick in
coinbase which was showing you that a
pretty aggressive bid from coinbase had
been stepping in
and so when you see that happening is
that something that people can uh
identify before it happens or is this
data only uh once it's actually occurred
right because it's not like on the
blockchain we can see like a mempool or
something like that instead you almost
have to see that it actually got filled
okay there was that spike in volume and
then it's you know maybe you can tell
almost in real time kind of right after
it occurs but uh you can't actually see
that so it's impossible for somebody to
front run the front runner to some
degree
yeah i guess so i guess i guess that's
uh accurate you know you could you could
see the the bids and asks right so you
can see are there bids and asks set in
the order book you know someone it's
like for you know for in layman's terms
if you're like on ebay right and you're
bidding for something you say okay you
know i don't deem the current you know
price that this is being priced at at
market value um you know where i'd be
interested in purchasing this so i'll
set a bid below you know if it gets
filled great if not then that's not what
i deem fair value for this right
uh and so it's pretty much the same
thing right you have someone coming in
and saying well i'm not interested in
buying btc at this price but i will be
interested at you know if we get down
below so i'll set a bid at that at that
price um and so it's a bit more nuanced
than that you get you know a lot of
spoofs in the order books and all that
kind of thing
but generally speaking that's kind of
the premise behind looking at bids and
asks right and then you can look at what
are the active bid well you know what
are the active orders coming through the
market um so you know the bids and asks
they're great to look at but at the end
of the day they're really just
advertisements what you really need to
see is you know what are the orders that
are actually getting filled because when
someone's setting a bitter ask again
it's an advertisement it's someone just
saying you know i'm i'm putting this in
the order book you know hear everyone
look at it right versus someone stepping
in the market and actually market buying
and so of course you can't see that
beforehand but we can see that as it's
occurring
and so you did see that uptick in volume
as well as cvd uh you know ticking up as
that started to occur once we broke
below 33 and this was on monday
so um and you saw in the in the day
after as well another kind of steady bid
during new york hours so there's some
type of entity or group of entities that
was interested in uh buying around that
33k area
when you mention spoofing real quick
explain what that is for folks who don't
understand some of the the kind of
complexity and nuance of what folks are
doing in these order books uh that that
can affect price to some degree
sure so um spoofing is something that's
like illegal in traditional markets
but in the bitcoin market because a lot
of you know these exchanges are more
unregulated it does occur a lot
the premise behind this is again bids
and asks are basically just
advertisements so
let's say that you know i wanted to
fill up my bags so what i could do is
and i'm a whale and price is starting to
run away from me i can set you know a
large wall of asks above the current
price cap off the price because no one's
going to want to buy into that big wall
of cell orders right
and then i can actually be filling my
bag so using those those uh you know
those fake asks the spoof asks to
actually generate liquidity because
everyone's going to close out their
lungs or short into that wall of asks so
that i can fill my bags where conversely
i could set a wall of bids below if i'm
trying to get out of the market because
no one's going to want to sell into that
big wall of buys meanwhile i'm actually
using that liquidity to exit the market
so again like there's a lot of nuance to
this um but when we talk about spoofing
that's what we're talking about is
basically using the bids and asks to
your advantage to kind of generate your
liquidity to get in and out of positions
and this is something again that's
illegal in traditional markets but
because a lot of these exchanges are
less regulated it does occur on a on a
fairly regular basis in the bitcoin
market got it and then let's look at the
uh the supply shock ratios we've been
talking about this now for uh for almost
a year uh i think and uh you've been all
over this so what are you seeing with
these supply shock ratios it looks like
it's pretty bullish in terms of what you
would expect right now in a price
drawdown
right so i think we first need to
preface with like in any market there's
supply and demand right and so
um there's been a lot of people that
have been saying what happened to the
supply shock right you're talking about
a supply shock right
for a supply shock to occur you need low
available demand you need low available
supply plus demand okay and so this is
just looking at the demand side so what
this is telling you is in layman's terms
it's showing you the movement of coins
from strong to weak hands or from weak
to strong hands and the way i'm defining
that is by the spending behavior of the
entities on the blockchain so you're
tracking the movement of coins from
entities that have a
high tendency to sell
to entities that have a low tendency to
sell right low tenancy to sell being
illiquid entities hence a liquid supply
shock ratio
and so what you can see is throughout
2017 we had an uptrend in this until
once we finally broke below that that
you know uptrend that marks the 2017 top
almost to almost to the tick
uh as well as we you know once we broke
below the uptrend from late 2020 early
2021 that kind of gave you a preface
that we were going to have this drawdown
in may
we continue to move up off of the summer
lows and this continues to just grind up
and up and up
but of course again this is only
speaking to the supply side so this is
just telling you the quality of
bitcoin's float is very healthy right
now but i do think the kind of
lackluster of demand on the other side
of the equation has been kind of driven
by this macro uncertainty um you know
we've talked about like monetary
tightening we've seen general you know
risk off behavior from the nasdaq and
just overall equities so
i think that's kind of
to blame for the lackluster of demand
but when we talk about what does the
supply side look like which i do think
is very important to still keep in mind
because that's one half of the equation
that still does look very healthy
you still do have very strong hoddling
behavior
yeah what's fascinating to me and i was
actually talking to somebody this
morning about it is like it feels like
there's basically a bifurcation of
people using bitcoin some of the folks
who are more the institutional investors
uh the wall street hedge funds et cetera
bitcoin is the riskiest asset they have
in their portfolio right it is the risk
asset it's kind of the pure macro asset
um and when you look at that uh they're
gonna sell it in times of the federal
reserve uh kind of talking tough and
talking about raising interest rates et
cetera you know risk off and let me go
back into more conservative assets uh
but then there's this whole community of
bitcoiners that actually treat bitcoin
as the reserve asset they don't sit
there and uh treat it as a risk asset so
they don't care what goes on at the fed
they're going to just continue to stack
and i think that's what you're seeing
here with these kind of strong hands um
they just continue to buy bitcoin and at
cheaper prices they get excited because
it's transferring it from the short term
kind of weak hands to the strong hands
which you know if people were paying
attention last summer you and i spent
literally week after week after week
talking about that theme and then
eventually it led to uh some you know
pretty crazy fireworks so let's look at
uh on the demand side whale balances
what uh what are you seeing here
yeah um if if you don't mind like just
to touch on what you just said yeah of
course i think like the big difference
between like now and then is back then
we still had a dovish fed right so you
still had a favorable monetary backdrop
for bitcoin versus now again you know
there's been a lot of fears around macro
uncertainty which is kind of you know in
my opinion driven this lackluster of
demand that we haven't seen
and then to comment on your other point
i completely agree i posted a chart this
week if if anyone's interested and wants
to like scroll back on my twitter i just
didn't throw it in the newsletter it's
looking at all entities i think we've
talked about this before actually on the
show it's looking at all entities less
than 10 btc and then comparing that to
overall circulating supply i mean this
chart literally goes up and to the right
and so this is just showing you exactly
what you just said and format data which
is just that there's a hardcore base of
you know hodlers that are just doll
across averaging into this asset no
matter what of course you know their
balance is uptick more so in the bull
market because you're more of
speculative market participants stepping
in
but generally yeah like you know they're
just continually stacking no matter what
the price is so the data definitely
backs up what you're saying
um to move on to whale balances
so as we just talked about supply side
looks great still lackluster of demand
um this is actually one of the one of
the few metrics that i think can kind of
give you a hint as to what's going on
with demand so this is looking at whale
balances and so what we're doing is
we're looking at all the entities with
over 1000 btc and so an entity being a
forensically clustered address based on
some of the data science that the glass
node team has done
and so we're taking all those entities
with over 1000 btc and then we're
filtering out all the known entities on
the blockchain so we're filtering out
exchanges which in my opinion is the
most important to filter out because
let's say you haven't filtered out for
exchanges you know you could see what's
perceived as a whale inflow when it's
actually coins moving on to an exchange
to be sold which of course is you know
perceived to be a bullish thing by you
but is actually bearish or conversely
you could see
what appears to be whales distributing
when meanwhile it's actually coins
moving off exchanges right and that's
actually a bullish thing that you're
perceiving to be bearish so it's very
important to filter out those exchanges
when you're when you're looking at this
and then as well we filter out grayscale
the purpose etf uh qbtc
and then what we get left with is just
the raw balance of whales right and so
as you can see if i was to you know zoom
a little further out you would see
throughout all of late 2020 up until
early 2021 we had this really aggressive
move up in wales uh it was the largest
period of whale accumulation in
bitcoin's history most of the most
amount of new whales stepping into the
market in bitcoin's history as well
after about february to march they
started distributing their coins all the
way back down into about august and we
had this big pop-up off the lows
and then they did start to accumulate
all the way up until kind of late
september early october and since that
time period so that's almost six months
ago they've just continually distributed
their coins
and so that's something that um you know
probably would have wanted to be paying
attention to admittedly i just hadn't
been watching this metric uh kind of
wish i was in in retrospect and of
course you know hindsight so it's 20 20
but you know since september uh whales
were distributing and then recently what
we've seen though is over the last week
or two we've seen them actually start to
accumulate again so if you look on the
right hand side you'll see that little
blue circle that i've highlighted you
see this big pop-up in wales holdings so
this is very interesting to me uh we're
kind of breaking out of this downtrend
of distribution
uh so you know i think this is this is
one of the few on-chain metrics that you
can actually look at
aside from perhaps like transactional
activity to give you a hint as to what's
going on on the demand side i think you
know if you had been watching this for
the last few months and seeing this
decline obviously showing you that
whales have been distributed but you
know over the last week or two starting
to see their
holdings tick up
i think that's very interesting
something you want to see kind of
continue over the next week or two to
see if we are starting to finally see
some demand from larger players begin to
step in yeah it's absolutely fascinating
to watch this play out um you've got
another chart here the uh bitcoin
relative transfer value breakdown by
size uh i'm not familiar with this one
so take me to school my friend what uh
what are you looking at here
sure so all we're doing here is we're
just taking all the transactions on the
blockchain and then we're just breaking
them down by size so we're saying
where is transactional volume where's
transfer volume being dominated
based on the size of the transactions
and so what we see is since 2020 we've
kind of just been this like perpetual
uptrend
of course you know a bit of fluctuation
here and there uh but generally just
been trending up since that time period
a lot of that has to do with
institutions being in the market as well
as transaction batching uh being done by
exchanges and so you know again
this is really just showing you that
kind of the big boys are running the
show if you will um you know larger
market participants are really kind of
dominating the transfer volume and then
if you go to the next chart you'll see
the same chart but it's looking at um
the the one we just looked at is looking
at transfer volume above 10 million
dollars this one that we're now looking
at is transfer volume below 100 000
so these are the smaller market
participants
generally retail and what you'll see is
that they've taken up a smaller and
smaller portion of volume over the last
year so
i think this also kind of shows you that
there's a decrease in kind of retail you
know speculative euphoria in the market
as well
and that generally you know the
bigger market participants you know the
larger transactional volume is
dominating the market right now
got it and then when we go ahead and we
look uh kind of at the opposite end uh
when we look at these uh transfer sizes
less than 100k that's basically just
showing us that uh it is really the the
large players not the small players
exactly
yeah so it's um it's pretty interesting
when you kind of look at
it it's impossible to deny this data
right um in terms of what we're seeing
uh all right let's um let's talk a
little bit about the flows into bitcoin
i know you've got kind of this like
almost like volume or flow chart here
what is this showing us
right so as we talked about i think part
of what's been driving the lackluster of
demand for btc over the last couple
months there's just been general risk
off behavior driven by macro uncertainty
uh whether that's you know what's going
on with russia or quantitative
tightening fears
and so like
this is looking at the correlation of
btc to the nasdaq and so what you'll see
is generally this is kind of spurious
right we go through these heavy periods
of correlation we draw down these can
kind of like brief decoupling periods
but over call it the last month or two
we've had a really strong correlation as
you can see kind of on the on the right
hand side this is kind of the largest
block of of correlation uh in recent
history
and so again i i think um i don't sound
like a broken record here but for a lot
of the reasons we just mentioned but to
break this correlation
i think you need two things so you
either need a traditional finance
rebound particularly the nasdaq which
would allow bitcoin to just trade as a
high data asset
you know whenever you're in risk on mode
you can start to see these correlations
break down as people go out further on
the risk curve so that's one way
if you start to see a lot of the macro
uncertainties subside and start to see a
rebound in risk on assets particularly
you know tech stocks
and just you know overall just the qqq
and the second way would be if we had
some type of catalyst that would draw in
idiosyncratic flows
so idiosyncratic is just like a fancy
word i like to use to sound smart which
just means unique flows to bitcoin right
and so what i'm saying here is that you
know unless we have some type of macro
rebound you're going to need some type
of event that forces that correlation to
break down to the upside ideally
could potentially be you know so
downside if you have terrible news
but i'm saying ideally you know to the
upside obviously
um so we're looking at you know several
different potential catalysts we've got
things like russia being rumored to
looking you know russia potentially
looking to mine bitcoin intel getting
involved in mining chips google looking
to store crypto when in their
partnership with coinbase apple and
microsoft talking about the metaverse el
salvador their bond raise coming up
which i think that'll get really
interesting if it's oversubscribed to
as well as rumors of other uh latin
american countries following el salvador
making their current making their legal
currency uh bitcoin so
i think you know
it's it's a bit foolish to just blindly
bet that a catalyst is going to occur
but i do think you know again always
trying to speak in an if-then format if
one of these events occurred then i
would expect
the kind of correlation the really heavy
correlation that we've had uh to risk on
equities to kind of break down
and so that's just something to kind of
keep in the back your mind if we do see
some one of these kind of catalysts take
place i would expect some type of
idiosyncratic flows to then come into
bitcoin but for now because we haven't
had anything like you know that's that's
uh causing those unique flows into btc
we are just kind of trading at the hip
of equities for the time being
and then let's talk lastly about
on-chain cost basis this is something
that i've been paying a lot of attention
to
and you've kind of gone back and charted
you know what's happened over the last
couple of years here what is this
telling you
yeah so i mean to back up for one second
i think like
there's two types of buyers in the
market so we have momentum buyers and we
have value buyers for btc
of course the difficult part is defining
what is momentum and what is value
because that's kind of subjective
because bitcoin doesn't have cash flows
it's just you know a very subjective
thing based on different strategies that
you like to implement to determine these
things
from a momentum perspective
i think this is where short-term holder
cost basis steps in
because if we look historically this has
kind of been the area that served as
either you know bull market support or
bear market resistance
and why is this you know the kind of
psychology behind this is that whenever
we're above short term holder cost basis
so the red line
is showing you that we're the shorter
term market participants or the
newer market participants because these
are entities that have been on the
blockchain for less than 155 days
they're in profit when we're above the
line right and so in bull markets we
come back and retest that line shorter
you know newer market participants don't
want to sell at a loss so people stop
selling when we retest that and we
continue up
when we flip below when we come into a
bear market once we're below they're now
in a state of loss right so they're now
under water in aggregate not every
single market participant but in
aggregate they're under water and so
whenever we have this underside re-test
of that level of the short-term hold of
realized price
or in other words short-term hold or
cost basis
that's you know it's it's a opportunity
for those market participants to exit at
break even
okay and so as we as we head down into
the bear you see these continuous
rejections of that line and so finally
we break above that right and then what
you want to see is breaking above and
then retesting that line as support um
and so as you'll see throughout 2017
this kind of served as support until we
broke below then it became heavy
resistance until we finally broke above
at the very bottom of the bear market
um heading into like the 2020 area
you'll see once we retested this in
september of 2020 then we you know was
off to the races
once we broke below in may we would have
been cautious until breaking back above
and retesting in september recently
we've broken below and so this is
something we talked about for a long
time for months we were talking about at
the time this was at the 53k area
talked about how we were gonna becoming
cautious once we broke below this area
because historically that's signaled a
good time to be cautious
we had this failed underside retest of
short-term short-term holder cost basis
and so for now you do want to kind of
maintain a bearish bias from a high time
frame momentum perspective
and so again this is for momentum-based
market participants uh the short-term
holder cost basis is dynamic based on
you know the the
you know the movement of market
participants on chain so it's now down
from 53k and currently sits at about
forty one thousand five hundred dollars
um and so this is kind of the area from
an unchained perspective that i would be
looking at to get uh to to be reclaimed
uh to say from a from a broader
standpoint that we have reclaimed
momentum for the market so with that in
mind that's that's for momentum based
market participants when we talk about
value-based
market participants
i think the kind of low 30s uh upper 20s
area is like a nice value area for btc
so this is partially based on price
action and price levels
it's also based on several kind of macro
bottom indicators
so like for example the 200 week moving
average a realized price and not
short-term older realized price just the
aggregated realized price
as well as delta price
and these are all kind of in the mid 20s
and so the way i'm kind of approaching
this personally and of course not
financial advice
is that you know calling the exact
bottom i think is a bit of a fools game
um and you know sometimes i think it's
as simple as just saying where does the
asymmetry lie
right and so i think at this time with a
lot of those kind of macro bottom
indicators in the low to upper 20s and
we're sitting you know hanging out in
the mid to low 30s i tend to think that
the low 30s to upper 20s is a value area
for btc and the asymmetry meaning the
potential
you know upside versus downside
is not skewed to the downside i think at
this time the asymmetry is skewed to the
upside meaning that the potential uh
downside is is lower than your potential
upside and you'll call it a 6 to 12 plus
month time frame and so the way i'm
personally approaching this in my
personal portfolio is that i'm not
trying to get too cute with this i'm
just kind of averaging in uh in the kind
of low 30s upper you know if we do see
the upper 20s area
you know i'm kind of just averaging in
over the next couple weeks or months
depending on how long it takes to kind
of bottom out but i'm not in any type of
rush to just lump sum and try to call
the pico bottom i think that's kind of a
fool's game and anyone telling you that
they know exactly where the bottom is is
either drinking their own kool-aid or
they're
or they're just kind of foolish and for
lack of of a better word so i i do tend
to think that these kind of levels or
you know in in the with a kind of
multi-month several year time horizon uh
there is extreme value for btc and the
kind of asymmetry is not skewed to the
downside at this time and of course this
doesn't rule out some type of you know
capitulation wick if you see some type
of you know one-off macro event or some
type of run for dollars like we saw in
march
i don't think you should be betting on
that i don't think that it's it's you
know very wise just to say i'm gonna
hold off on averaging into btc
whatsoever um if you are a value buyer
because you're betting on some type of
macro breakdown
maybe if you're a momentum buyer you
step out of the market and say until we
reclaim you know whether it's from an
unchanged perspective that short term
holder cost basis so if you're a
technical person some type of moving
average or whatever price level that
deems you to feel like we've reclaimed
that kind of high time for momentum
that's different but from a value from a
value buyer perspective
i i don't think it's wise to just be
sitting around waiting for some type of
macro capitulation event that may not
come
but with that in mind it is possible so
i also don't think that it's wise to
just try to lump sum and time the bottom
and so that's kind of the reasoning
behind why i'm personally just kind of
averaging into these levels
my friend you are absolutely killed it
here my last question for you and then
we gotta run is uh sentiment how are you
thinking about uh kind of the twitter
sentiment in relationship to the actual
uh kind of underlying fundamentals and
data that you're watching here it seems
like people were really scared and
fearful and now maybe that's loosening
up a little bit
yeah um yeah it definitely seems like
there's a lot of kind of anxiety amongst
uh i don't know some of the folks on
twitter i try not to honestly pay too
much attention to that because if you
look at like the fear and greed index
it's been in you know heavy fear for two
months now so if you know if you're kind
of using that as like a buy or sell
indicator i don't really find that super
actionable right because in a bear
market you know we're in heavy fear for
like a year or two and then a bull
market you're in heavy greed for months
and months and months so and generally i
think um
i think using something like a fear and
greed index is not entirely useful but
it does seem like amongst you know some
of the folks at least on on twitter that
the sentiment does kind of lean pretty
bearish
and people do kind of feel like we're
we're uh entering some type of you know
macro bear market so
i don't know it's something just to add
and to consider but i don't think that
sentiment in its entirety is necessarily
actionable because of
kind of what i just talked about
i think you're on to it man i think you
uh you're ahead of the game right now
how we uh how we looking on followers we
got a million yet closing in
50 oh
600k though
you know i've been surprised with
the follower growth because
you know you'd think whenever the market
is down that there wouldn't be new
market entrance coming in but i do find
it really interesting
and i'm sure you probably noticed this
as well with your own follower account
that it's continuing to
see somewhat of a steady increase
actually i had more followers this month
than last month which not saying that
necessarily in like a braggy way i just
do find that interesting because bitcoin
is down pretty substantially on a kind
of month-to-month basis so it is showing
you that there's you know new market
participants that are coming in and and
people are continually interested in
bitcoin no matter the price i do find
that something interesting to know
you're killing it my friend i appreciate
you coming on every single week or every
other week whenever you can make time
for us
uh i always like to say that will
clemente he brings the noise he just got
he's got so much heat that he brings in
terms of the data analysts you're
getting better and better so i
appreciate you uh you coming on my
friend
thanks so much you guys take it easy
appreciate you all right